è la tutti ragazzi pervenuti a questo lo
video siamo su qt che sarebbe non lo so
giochiamo penso sia una versione io ho
visto un paio di scream quindi sono
sicuro che non è oro tranquilli
tranquilli non chiudete tranquilli non
vi cagate sotto anche se la luce
sfarfalla perché sono sicuro che non sia
un horror cioè almeno da quello che ho
visto poi magari un troll
quindi mi spunta satana però non lo
posso sapere dagli script che ho visto
mi sembrava non non oro a mano lei
sporco il mio schermo in mezzo orco
demonio cosa fosse sporco
c'è una faccina come cursore al centro
che non la vedete perché talmente
piccola ve lo dico io comunque una
faccina tipo questa bellissimo
vabbè allora vi fa giusta premessa pt è
un gioco o demonio look bin ein chi
guarda dietro di te lo salva ciao
ma cos'è bellissimo nove fermi storici
ept e un gioco horror dove c'è questo
corridoio che si ripete all'infinito
credo che questa sia la versione troll
dico gioco lice ciao come stai
sono felice piacervi e bellissimo mi
sono cagato sotto per niente sì ma
facciamo qualcosa qua o continui a
salutarmi ciao vado avanti io che è
stato un piacere bene chiude la porta
non si è così chiusa buongiorno
praticamente e si ripete questo
corridoio all'infinito è un horror
praticamente però non credo che questo
non sia proprio un horror buongiorno io
vado avanti che qua qua non so cosa devo
farci questo moscerino stranissimo cai
piacere ora sta diventato tutto molto
strano
bene col c nella gigante a quanto pare
non posso andare di qua quindi
l'approccio saltarti però grazie
dell'ospitalità comunque gentili browser
sembra un limon dei mondi di ricchi e
morti però non è proprio la stessa cosa
forse dovrei cominciare la webcam con la
oro adesso rende più giustizia ciao
amico mio switchato in modalità horror
così potete farmi paura amici miei
venite cugino venuti in mente sta cosa
geniale e geniale sembra mio padre
questo nella foto va bene continua ad
andare avanti finché non succede
qualcosa anche solo per capitolo
dovrebbe succedere visto che il
corridoio è sempre uguale
io non ho capito se si può finire c'è
effettivamente se ha un senso se
continuiamo così tutto il giorno
bellissime foto complimenti ma vado
avanti all'infinito torno indietro che
non ho capito mentito tornare indietro
in tutto questo perché magari è un gioco
ma poi minimi ma sto continuando a fare
il giro per la milionesima volta ragazzi
mi spiegate cosa dovevo fare quali parla
giovanni parla dimmi qualcosa fino alla
facciamo giovanni e pino così andiamo
due nomi decenti alle persone cosa devo
fare qua vi prego ditemelo che un'ora
che giro lo stesso punto qt per che cosa
sta per quanto tempo per finire suo
gioco non faccio una lampadina qui ma
come ho acceso le luci salve ma l'ho
mica visto che c'era gente qua va bene
ho acceso le luci ragazzi quindi
tranquilli giorno
adesso vedo le famiglie degli altri
disegni che belli che erano lui è
fantastico
questi ancora meglio qualcuno mi spieghi
vi prego io non so più cosa dire
nel caso lo stesse chiedendo no non l'ho
pagato questo gioco meno male perché
sennò sarebbe stato molto molto strano
però va bene andiamo avanti
tutti i ragazzi incredibile si ripeta la
stampa salve
cosa sta diventando sto gameplay
buongiorno mi fai posso passare posso
entrare grazie nel gioco originale st
porta qua a un certo punto si apriva e
usciva un mostro orribile ma proprio di
quelli brutti forte e ragazzi quindi non
so se anche stavolta succederà sta cosa
spero di sì perché sono poi così di
vedere che cosa esce in questo gioco
andati via tutti mali spegniamo le luci
che dite che facciamo un pò più di
atmosfera la situazione sta degenerando
quello è un ipad non accarezzare il cane
così tutto il tempo prova bene non fa
niente vi state divertendo crostate
cos'è qualcuno mi spieghi
vi prego datemi la risposta che sto
giocando
cos'è sta roba incredibile orco demonio
che è successo è un portale va bene
salve giorno vado passo
ok ma tranquilli finite pure i lavori in
pace e tanto io non fate caso a me che
passo nei corridoi dopo questo dovrei
giocare al vero pt giusto per dare una
svolta alla mia vita allora credo di
conoscere talmente bene ma basta co sti
cani credo riconoscere talmente bene
videogiochi di questo tipo che a un
certo punto si spegnerà tutta la musica
e ritornerà l'atmosfera un pochettino
horror scommettete non è questo il punto
sono i personaggi dei simpson disegnati
male teoricamente però è da questa parte
va bene grazie signor televisore cosa
cosa ma non fa niente niente siamo cosa
sto giocando viper vi supplico di temi
che qual è il problema
no ragazzi cosa stiamo assistendo ma tu
puoi mai sarà il computer sulle scale ma
che problemi hai
attenzione ragazzi che quella situazione
si fa proprio nightlife buongiorno e
vabbè la disco c masso gioca
psichedelico c'è chi sale chi l'ha
giocato si è bevuto 85 red bull prima
non ha senso
comunque il miglior club in cui sono
stato nella mia vita se un giorno mi
ubriacherò talmente tanto da mettermi un
pesce in testa ditemelo prima per favore
fate melo notare perché sennò non ha
senso posso mi scusi signora banana mi
fa entrare per favore grazie a questi
sono dei ragni dovrebbero essere come
fai a essere così così contento di avere
dei ragni in testa zio non accarezzare i
ragni che schifo gli avanti laveno
comunque complimenti perché esso gioco
merita cioè non ho mai visto niente di
meglio in tutta la mia vita
questa divertente è cambiata la stanza
se riuscite a cambiare la stanza dopo un
po non c'è proprio il muro qua anche le
società è comparso c'era un muro finto
c'è un ragno gigante però iraniano otto
zampe
nei sette tele marca una ecco che si
sono riuscirà anni mille dei quali avrei
paura però pagano di fango mi spiegate
qual è il vostro problema di vita potete
andare a casa vostra per favore casa mia
perché c'è un cane in una culla
spiegami ragazzi già pt non aveva senso
in sé per sé come gioco cioè era
difficile trovarli in senso ma questo
mammamia le batte tutte lo giuro
comunque ragazzi si emettono un jobs che
il vero adesso diventano i miei eroi
sarebbe veramente incredibile e
inaspettato this way ma l'abbiamo già
fatta sta cosa
sì che devo fare qua spiega mi ma è
domanda o se qualcuno sopra aspetta un
attimo
salve ora quanto è contento sto ragno è
bellissimo veramente non so che dire ah
ok signori un gatto rana il gatto rana
mi mancava però va beh questo è questo
non lo so non saprei neanche descrivere
l'opera ok è pieno di rane sono belli si
fonda vertici qualcosa qua dietro lo
intravedo il bagno non lo vedete voi più
o meno si intravede roba tutta colorata
strana peccato che non si apre il bagno
perché quello al bagno di pitti più o
meno dovrebbe essere salve è un piacere
conoscerla devo capire è finita la
musica a una ripartita
pensavo fosse un colpo di scena questa
invece la rana missile va bene
vabbè ragazzi concluso guardo un cookie
perché e ti ma sarà vi giuro non lo so
un ora ve lo giuro che ora davanti ci
sono sempre le stesse stanze però è
stato è stato illuminante giocare questo
giocare nel senso la mia vita penso sia
cambiata ho capito che posso dare un
maggior valore ai giochi che faccio di
solito perché questo ne ha veramente
poco tanto non avevo notato che c'era il
postino mille volte ho fatto sostanza
dal postino non avevo ancora visto vabbè
chissenefrega
ci sono ed è teoricamente dei modi
segreti per aprire tipo la porta del
bagno e poi o per completare il gioco
proceduto non so cosa devi fare
sinceramente per fare ste cose perché
veramente difficile però ok io spero che
video vi sia piaciuto spero che abbiate
trovato anche voi il significato di
questo gioco nel vostro io interiore
cioè perché alla fine quello che portano
vedere i fantasmi e questo che importa
anche quelli dietro maledizione
questo gioco è incredibile comunque ho
amato ogni singolo centimetro di questa
casa di questo gioco guai complimenti
bravi bravi vorrei
in tutto questo chiudere in bellezza
dicendo che nel 2020 forse giocherò pt
con l'originale non è vero non si può
più giocare perché mi hanno tolto dagli
store però almeno abbiamo questo è già
qualcosa
più o meno ma vedere se per curiosità
dopo st stanza riparte tutto come sempre
per curiosità
va bene spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi mi piace iscrivetevi al canale
schiacciatela campanellina che così gli
arrivano le notifiche dei nuovi video
che escono io se uscirò mai da questo
corridoio ve lo faccio sapere
e noi come sempre ci rivediamo al
prossimo video finalmente sono entrato
in discoteca almeno mi diverto bella
ragazzi che cosa ho appena giocato io
[Musica]